[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, Stillwater.
Whatcha doing?
Hello, Karl.
I'm just about to have my lunch.
Would you like to join me?
OK.
What are you having?
All of my favorite things.
This is called a bento.
What's that?
It's called persimmon.
Have you ever tried them?
No.
Are they good?
Oh, I like them very much.
But everyone likes
things differently.
What happens if I
don't like them?
It can be fun to try new
things, even if in the end
we don't enjoy them.
If you don't like
them, then you'll know.
OK.
I'll try some persimmon.
Would you like chopsticks?
Sure.
How do they work?
Here, I know a trick.
They're like little
pinchy fingers.
It's a little bit crunchy
like an apple and sweet.
I like it.
Would you like to
try something else?
I'd like to try everything.
Wonderful.
This is seaweed.
You mean from the ocean?
Yes, from the ocean.
It's slippery and
crunchy at the same time.
That is lotus root.
It doesn't taste like anything.
Is this a carrot?
It's called gobo,
or burdock root.
Well, it doesn't
taste like a carrot.
It's salty.
That ube, purple sweet potato.
It tastes like a
potato, but sweet.
Gomai, spinach with sesame.
This tastes way better
than regular spinach.
Tofu.
I've heard of tofu.
It's squishy.
I like it.
Is that spaghetti?
Those are soba noodles
made from buckwheat.
You dip and slurp.
It's cold and chewy.
Ah, you saved umaboshi
for last, salted plums.
They're an acquired taste.
But I'm proud of you for trying.
I'm proud of me too.
I'm going to try new
things all the time now.
I might find a new favorite
food like persimmons.
Do you have any more?
I do indeed.
[MUSIC PLAYING]